bienvenue dans afrique connecte le
continent compte environ 500 millions
d'internautes soit 38 % de la population
un potentiel énorme de croissance mais
aussi un boulevard pour la
cybercriminalité
selon l'expert en sécurité kapersky
l'afrique a été la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 à la cybercriminalité semble être
devenu la principale menace sur le
continent pour en parler on va se
connecter à tunis avec rim abassi
chercheuse en cybersécurité sélectionné
à parmi les 50 meilleures femmes
africaines en cybersécurité elle a reçu
le prix du meilleur jeune chercheur en
informatique de l'académie des arts et
des sciences de tunis bonjour à vous un
rima abassi merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans l'affairé connect
bonjour et merci de m'avoir invité de me
donner cette occasion de partager avec
vous quelques unes de mes l'information
merci alors je disais la
cybercriminalité c'est la nouvelle
menace sur le continent l'afrique est
elle devenue la nouvelle terre de
prédilection des cybercriminels
la cybersécurité c'est c'est un concept
on va dire qu'il va toucher le monde
hanté actuellement de par le volume
énorme de données que nous échangeons de
par le nombre d'objets connectés et
l'afrique est un continent plein
croissance ne va pas déroger à la règle
et en fait c'est un peu comme vous dites
la nouvelle terre de prédilection pour
la cybercriminalité pour des raisons
assez simple
tout d'abord parce que nous manquons
cruellement de compétences qualifiées en
termes de cybersécurité d'après les
dernières estimations on estime cela à
son mines
cyber experts
dont on aurait besoin
à court terme est ce le problème c'est
que même les compétences que nous avons
sont vont être très très vite des
marchés par d'autres d'autres pays
d'autres continents vu que c'est une
denrée rare dans le monde entier c'est
une pénurie mondiale et en fait ça fait
que on estime que 96% des incidences de
cyber sécurité ne seraient pas signalés
on resterait non résolus ça c'est la
première la première qods la deuxième
clause bas tout simplement parce que les
budgets alloués à la cyber sécurité en
afrique reste très très très insuffisant
on estime que 66% des entreprises
d'investissement de 200 mille euros par
an contre avenant tendance mondiale en
plus même la répartition de ce budget
elle ne se fait pas de manière équitable
entre les différentes domaines donc par
exemple les investissements en
cybersécurité dans les équipements et de
l'ordre de 35% en afrique alors que dans
le reste du monde c'est de l'ordre de
14% donc on fait on investit beaucoup
plus dans les infrastructures et
haytillon crois que ces infrastructures
l'avant nous devons nous protéger auquel
sa haine mais ça ne protège pas
complètement et paradoxalement bas 5 %
seulement des investissements seront
dédiés à la sécurité des données à la
détection des incidents au suivi des
menaces ou encore la gestion des
identités contre 16% pour le reste du
monde donc vous voyez que réellement
cela
aide à créer ce problème de
cybercriminalité et bien sûr le problème
le troisième problème un navire est le
fait qu'il ya très très peu de mesures
qui sont prises en faveur de la
formulation et l'adoption de politiques
en matière de cyber défense bas par
exemple le 15 pays africains seulement
possède une stratégie nationale de
cybersécurité
si seulement en signer la convention de
budapest de sur la cybercriminalité en
2001 on vous voyez tout cela va
renforcer en fait
7 cette dernière position de 10 ans ou
ceux ce retard de l'afrique en termes de
cybersécurité est donc en termes de
cybercriminalité ou par le même on parle
de menaces a emmené voir même de chaos
numérique c'est la réalité un risque au
real
ben c'est un risque réel parce que tout
simplement lorsque vous n'êtes pas
préparé et que vous n'avez pas les
bonnes personnes et les bonnes
stratégies qui sont mises en place bah
vous risquez de subir des attaques qui
vont être désastreuses et ça on le
remarque ces derniers mois dernières
années on va dire on a noté que la
plupart des attaques ont visé les
infrastructures critiques donc
l'eau l'électricité etc le service
bancaire aussi et ça fait que ça risque
réellement de créer le chaos de dons
dans différents pays et dans tout le
continent bien sûr quels sont les pays
les plus touchés par ce phénomène la
cyber délinquance cybercriminalité
ben on aura tendance à dire que ce sont
les pays bas qui n'en qui nous je dirais
les pays qui n'ont pas investi dans
cette stratégie nationale donc de
cybersécurité donc ça va être plus les
pays de de l'afrique de l'ouest audois
l'est de l'ouest 10 ans mais en fait
tous les pays sont touchés par ce
problème de cybersécurité parce qu'on
reste finalement dans le cyberespace est
comme une chaîne donc si l'un des
maillons doit être faite le bas toute la
chaîne doit être fiable tout simplement
est ce que la pandémie de kovy de 19 a
eu un impact sur les actes de
cybercriminalité
en fait la pandémie elle a fait que nous
nous sommes devenus vulnérables à tous
les égards parce que tout simplement
pendant cette crise nous étions
dépendants plus que jamais des systèmes
informatiques des donne au téléphone
dell de l'internet pour travailler pour
communiquer pour faire des achats pour
partager pourra recevoir des
informations et en fait c'était une
aubaine pour les cybercriminels vu que
on dit que voilà la pandémie a renforcé
la digitalisation dans certains pays
mais paradoxalement elle a intensifié
les menaces et les risques de en termes
de cybersécurité bas tout simplement
parce que
dans l'une de ces raisons c'est que la
plupart des entreprises 10 ans les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui
étaient obligés de passer en télétravail
ont adopté la proche
apportez votre propre appareil
device ce qui signifie que l'employé en
fait il va utiliser ses propres
appareils personnels téléphones
tablettes aux autres pour accéder aux
informations de l'entreprise et bien sûr
ces équipements là ne sont pas
sécurisées de la même façon que les
équipements qui était au sein même de
l'entreprise
donc lorsque on va utiliser un
ordinateur personnel pour accéder aux
données de l'entreprise bat l'entreprise
sera plus que jamais exposé aux cyber
attaques parce que la moindre des choses
c'est que un employé ne va pas forcément
avoir un antivirus qui sera à jour il va
pas forcément faire des analyses
régulièrement il va pas forcément avoir
un pare-feu il va pas utiliser du
cryptage pour échanger des données donc
cet environnement de travail à domicile
réellement ne disposent donc la plupart
des cas de presque pas de l'usure
sophistiqué de prévention et de
détection que l'on aurait eu au sein de
l'entreprise en plus les réseaux wifi
comme va utiliser chez soi sont beaucoup
plus facile à attaquer que les réseaux
de l'entreprise filaire ou sans fil bien
sûr aussi l'erreur humaine qui était
déjà avant de la pandémie une source de
source majeure de préoccupation elle est
encore plus aujourd'hui parce que
involontairement ou imprudemment les
employés vont permettre à certaines
personnes d'accéder ou de mauvaises
personnes d'accéder aux informations
parce que lorsqu'on est dans son
entreprise en est plus ou moins
concentrés on est dans un environnement
bien précis bien clair on est je dirais
sur ses gardes alors que chez soi on
peut être perturbé par les membres de sa
famille par des individus qui vous
rendent visite par le téléphone
personnel qui sonne et c est tout ça
fait que le nombre d'erreurs humaines a
augmenté en flèche et ça fait que
finalement le nombre d'attaqués a
augmenté rendez vous compte de pendant
la pandémie en à une attaque en lançant
géant ciel toutes les 14 secondes donc
vous imaginez cc c'est énorme à la c
avant de se pencher sur tes se cache
derrière les actes de cybercriminalité
de cyber attaques ce chiffre les pertes
dépassent 4 milliards de dollars c'est
un coût financier énorme et c'est
significatif pour les économies
africaines
très significatif j'allais justement
vous vous donnez un autre chiffre ben on
estime que 60 % des pme qui ont connu
une attaque une attaque majeure durant
2020 en cesser leur activité dans les
six mains donc ça vous donne une idée
sur ce ce qui s'est passé dans long
terme de perte ou de moncaut gagner
parce que la perte de vos données la
paire gré de vos deux du travail
du coup c'est vraiment très très très
très élevé et j'ai d'ailleurs aussi un
chiffre qui concerne les banques
africaines qui a été donnée par une
entreprise marocaine donc en afrique ils
estiment dans les banques africaines en
fait qu'ils en ont signalé des
cyberattaques on estime à peu près 800
mille euros
pour les derniers en termes de pertes
tandis que le coût moyen de chacun fait
infections informatiques qui dut un
logiciel malveillant coûte 9000 euros
aux entreprises africaines en moyenne
donc vous imaginez la répercussion on
t'aime de fouet en termes de faire comme
métier en termes de même de moncany
alors la cybercriminalité s'exprime sous
diverses formes de quelle menace par le
ton commence exerce-t-elle qui sont les
cibles éléments de réponse avec grâce à
yaya
ap les brouteurs en côte d'ivoire où il
ya ou boys au nigeria les petits
arnaqueurs en ligne des années 2000
poser dans les cyber cafés de quartier
donc plus grand chose à voir avec les
organisations cybercriminelles
d'aujourd'hui autrefois auteur d'
arnaque aux sentiments ou de petits
rançonnage sur la toile les attaques
actuelles sont désormais le fait
d'individus bien rodée et d'entités
organisé pour rappel le terme
cybercriminalité englobe l'ensemble des
crimes commis sur internet ou via des
réseaux ou des outils informatiques avec
la progression du numérique et notamment
celle du passage du cash au paiement
mobile en afrique le secteur des
services financiers a fait un boom
colossal mais dans cette évolution la
cyber sécurité demeure le parent pauvre
manque de compétences et absence de
sensibilisation des entreprises
l'afrique reste très vulnérable aux
cyber attaques
pour y palier en 2018 s'ouvrait au
sénégal une école de cybersécurité
location
dvd
la définition est la question
la cybercriminalité est l'une des formes
les plus prolifiques de criminalité
internationale un impact annuel sur
l'économie mondiale qui s'élèverait à 10
5 milliards de dollars d'ici 2025 les
sommes colossales qui incite les états à
s'en préoccuper davantage au mois de
décembre le président ivoirien alassane
ouattara a annoncé le dégagement de 18
milliards de francs cfa en 2022 pour
lutter contre les brouteurs ces
champions de larnack en ligne ces
dernières années des groupes organisés
en vue jours parmi les plus connus
figurent le collectif anonymous
militants sur internet pour la défense
de la justice la politique ou la
religion en 2016 ils ont lancé le
hashtag pauvre africa pour dénoncer les
gouvernements africains qu'ils jugeaient
corrompu gouvernement et même compagnie
ils prennent en otage les données des
entreprises pour dénoncer leurs failles
selon les experts d'autres catégories de
cybercriminels existe les script kiddies
qui malgré leurs faibles connaissances
en sécurité informatique tente à
longueur de journée d'infiltrer des
systèmes suivent ensuite les individus
qualifiés puis les groupes criminels
organisés tout en haut de l'échelle on
trouve les states sponsored des groupes
financés par des états dont la mission
est de collecter des données sur
d'autres états à des fins financières ou
géopolitiques
le dernier scandale d'espionnage en date
via le logiciel pegasus aurait ciblé
près de cinquante mille numéros de
téléphone l'enquète mondiale qui a été
menée par le consortium de journalistes
pour des mots forbidden stories en lien
avec amnesty international a révélé que
des gouvernements clients de
l'entreprise
n est ce une entreprise de cyber
surveillance israélienne
utiliser le logiciel espion pegasus pour
cibler pour espionner des personnes qui
sont des défenseurs des droits humains
des journalistes ou des personnalités
politiques sur la société civile le 17
janvier une rencontre entre eux des
diplomates africains et leurs homologues
mondiaux est à new york objectif
discuter d'un nouveau traité des nations
unies pour lutter contre la
cybercriminalité
un nouveau traité donc des nations unies
pour lutter contre la cybercriminalité
initiée par la russie qui doit voir le
jour auquel les pays africains sont
appelés à participer activement
riba abassi parmi les préoccupations
majeures au niveau international le
cyberterrorisme également sur le
continent cela a pour conséquence aussi
de la cyber censure qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire sur l'action des étals sont à la
fois régulateur mais aussi coupable de
la situation cela va dépendre des états
certains oui sont plus ou moins complice
parce qu on vous l'avait dit dans votre
reportage ben ils ont financé ces
groupes là pour essayer d'en tirer parti
certains sont coupables en ce sens un
peu la politique de l'autruche non
pillards et un taux va bien en
investira en prendra les choses en main
là le jour où il y aura un grave
incident donc là aussi
ils prennent pas les choses au sérieux
ils sont aussi des fois ils ne peuvent
pas défaut à prendre les choses au
sérieux parce qu'ils n'ont pas comme on
l'a dit les moyens ou les compétences
pour les fêtes pour les faire donc
réellement ce ça va dépendre du c'est au
cas par cas mais bon disons que en
laisser certains pays essaient de
trouver le juste milieu d'essayer de
2,2 de défendre disant leurs cyber
espace du mieux qu'ils le peuvent a
marqué une courte pause et se retrouver
un instant pour poursuivre dans afrique
connecte à rester avec nous
retour dans afrique honnête consacré la
cyber criminalité en afrique et nous
sommes avec rima abassi de cuir tunis
chercheuse en cyber sécurité
on l'a vu dans le sujet rima abassi
l'action d'un collectif célèbre de
hackers anonymous
c'est un collectif de pirates d'experts
capables de mettre hors service des
sites ils ont lancé une initiative
hashtag up africa
ce sont des web terroristes pour
certains des robins du web pour d'autres
par quels moyens techniques ils agissent
en fait ce sont comme vous l'avez dit
c'est un mouvement c'est tout un souci
c'est tout un mouvement de fait ce n'est
pas une une organisation donc en fait
ils agissent par le fait de ne pas être
centralisées pas d'un non pas de
hiérarchie donc pas de hiérarchie c'est
un mouvement complètement décentralisé
sans hiérarchie engrais helmand comme le
dit
l'anthropologue gabriella coleman en
fait ils agissent tout simplement à
travers des initiatives individuelles
donc tout le monde peut faire une vidéo
pour faire une action signée anonyme
hausse ils ont un logo ils ont le masque
donc leur emblème se masquer la est en
fait voilà donc ils agissent à travers
ces des actions qui sont complètement
décentralisée et des initiatives
individuelles qui défendent
principalement les libertés sur internet
et il lutte aussi contre la corruption
des états comment est-ce que ce qu'on
peut évaluer finalement leur capacité de
nuisance
en fait ce qu'ils font c'est plus du
activisme disons du machisme à dire que
finalement ils vont ils vont juste dire
voilà on n'est pas d'accord ou montre
que la plupart d'eux des gens ne sont
pas d'accord ça a été fait notamment de
mille vies 2008 avec l'église de la
scientologie lorsqu'il sent carrément
ils ont pris là l'algorithme de google
en faisant en sorte que lorsqu'une
personne chez des informations sur cette
église il tombe sur des sites
d'opposants la doctrine et ils ont fait
ça aussi en 2012 lorsqu'ils ont lancé
l'opération black-out en réponse à la
fermeture de mega blood et il se sent
attaqué au braille en fait en fermant
décès des serveurs du fbi ils ont fait
la même chose pendant le printemps arabe
en fermant des serveurs
d'autorité disons
administrative publique dans les pays du
printemps arabe leur dernière action en
date c'est suite à la mort de jack floyd
donc avec le collectif blacklight
battles et ils ont menacé la police de
millau police donc leur action c'est
plutôt l hérault bondi katif donc en
fermant des sites en arrêtant des
serveurs en propageant des messages
plutôt que bon voilà donc c'est ce genre
de nuisances si vous voulez un autre
niveau on trouve les brouteurs on va
écouter à ce propos notre expert jean
jacques bauguil et docteur en sciences
de l'information et de la communication
auteurs de cet ouvrage la
cybercriminalité une menace pour le
développement
c'est dans quel sens ça devient tout
simplement des
[Musique]
cuisinettes et puis en prix aux
différentes formes cette partie de
l'année prochaine
j'ai réduit chantal
tout ce qui est notre héritage
dans toutes sortes les abattre
dans le sentimental donc ça va pas celui
qui est des plus répandues que ça passe
de trois est lui
une fascination des ventes
immobilières etc l'important est que
j'ai donc intérieur les capacités et les
certain nombre jules la
manipuler des personnes
général à l'étranger
les mavs sait comment à échapper aux
griffes de ces broutards
comme l'a dit
votre expert en fait ils vont utiliser
disons le je dirais pas la naïveté mais
l'éthique ou disons là les sentiments de
certaines personnes qui vont essayer de
dupes et en se prétendant en prétendant
un problème imaginaire où un héritage un
an et demi dans une fausse loterie et
c'est donc en fait ils vont utiliser ce
ce set forth open de persuasion pour
essayer d'obtenir des informations ou de
l'argent donc l'idée c'est d'essayer
d'être sur vos gardes de ne jamais
envoyer d'argent à des personnes quand
tu viens de rencontrer qu'on rentre
qu'on a rencontrés depuis peu il faut
surtout pas envoyé de photo intime parce
que réellement il ya un grand aussi
problème quand c'est renoncer parce
qu'apres par la suite y vais avoir du du
chantage etc il faut pas dévoiler des
coordonnées personnelles ou des données
personnelles à des inconnus même si ces
inconnus vous paraissent séduisant tout
ce que vous voulez il faut toujours
essayer de vérifier la véracité de leurs
propos il faut leur poser des petites
questions
personnelles pour vérifier pour être sûr
pour qu'il n'ya pas d'incohérence dans
leurs propos lorsque vous avez des
messages par courrier électronique faut
surtout pas y répondre ou cliqué faut
vérifier vérifier l'adresse rifi et ce
qui est pas d'erreur dans les adresses
électroniques que l'on reçoit il faut
être conscient que la police ou où la
gendarmerie ne vont pas vous envoyer des
des demandes par mail donc il faut pas
répondre à ce genre aussi de
communication donc il faut être tout
simplement en alerte il faut toujours
être critique vis-à-vis de ce que vous
recevez des avis des des gens que vous
rencontrez qui des profils que vous
voyez aussi il faut être un peu
suspicieux parce que réellement douala
leur force c'est leur force de séduction
et de persuasion et qui fait que voilà
il dit certaines personnes pour l'export
extorquer de l'argent ou des
informations critiques il faut surtout
pas envoyer ses informations
personnelles via je sais n'importe quel
média il faut vraiment être sûr que
c'est votre banque ou c'est votre
vraiment il faut être sûr du
destinataire à fond de partager des
informations critiques on va écouter un
nouveau jean jacques bouilly sur les
stratégies de lutte face aux cyber
menaces
ses nièces je sais que les bonnes
victoires à
2 ans quand une approche est déjà en
statique avec les miens ce qu'on m'a
sidéré il ya le but les années
2011 2013 14 un certain nombre de lois
et minières pour
véritablement rim qu'il est cela il doit
aller avec ibm i pans de la séquence
visant certains de ses membres abonnés
de sa
commission qui y travaillent ne lui
casse mis en place même travail avec un
lot de rites et aussi des communications
alain jacques traumatique et nos nuits
c'est sûr que si vous allez cela par
contre rester
régulièrement il y amérique lomé sont
alimentés et il a tout cas il a le
devoir de signaler les escrocs du net
art sera tous non plus qu'il soit arrêté
régulière 500 dépression elle aussi un
travail de sensibilisation
qui
était menée aussi
menacer la faire parce que à l'avenir
que lancé récemment baissé que dans
certains quartiers et ses cieux de la
femme comme ribeiro
certains dansent est négatif et le
démarrage d'un président nous dise de
monde hier avec des finales est ça qui m
étonne quartier parce que nous allons
devoir
prénoms originaux
parce que généralement mil et maïs aussi
bien qu'il ne va souvent à passer mais
le cnc légendes jim flaherty qui est
fait et nous on essayera donc la
chapelle que il à sa fin plus forcément
alors visiblement ce n'est pas facile de
mener des stratégies ont lutté contre la
cyberdélinquance la cyber criminalité
interpol a d'ailleurs lancé une
initiative pour mettre en place un
nouveau bureau des opérations sur la
cybercriminalité
oui en fait interphone a fait tout un
travail en fait pour aider
disons à les pays membres de
l'organisation
de pour lutter contre la
cybercriminalité
tout d'abord il en a recensé en fait les
cinq plus grandes menaces pour que en
puis sous les pays puissent se
concentrer sur une menace sur ces
menaces il s'agit principalement des est
ce qu est ce qu cris en ligne les faux
email et sms l extrait l'extorsion
numérique qui dont on parlait tout à
l'heure les faux ordres de mouvements
les reins essentielle je vous ai parlé
de ça tout à l'heure et les botnet par
la suite en fait ils ont mis en place
toute une stratégie
tout d'abord en aidant à former les pays
membres à travers un programme complet
de formation qui est adapté aux besoins
des participants parce que comme l'a dit
l'expert scientifique allemand
sensibiliser reste la première chose est
la chose la plus importante à faire
parce que si tout le monde est conscient
de la gravité de ce qui peut se passer
de ce qui peut aider des risques et des
menaces bah on a déjà résolu disons la
moitié du problème ensuite ils ont mis
en place dont qu'interpol a mis en place
un centre de de cyber fusion donc le cfc
qui a réuni les experts en
cybercriminalité des services chargés de
l'application de la loi et du secteur
privé afin de recueillir et d'analyser
toutes les informations disponibles sur
les activités criminelles dans le
cyberespace et ainsi fournir au pays des
renseignements cohérent exploitables
susceptibles de donner lieu à une s'ils
ont par la suite opérationnels en vue
d'empêcher les infractions et de
faciliter l'identification des
malfaiteurs aussi à travers leur
laboratoire d'informatique légal ils ont
mis à la disposition des pays donc les
moyens de renforcer leurs capacités de
détection et d'exploitation des éléments
de preuve numérique juste monde c'est
pour pouvoir retracer ces attaques là
dans le cadre du travail quotidien de la
police entière parce que là il faut il
nous faut une police du numérique merci
beaucoup a avoué rim abassi merci
et merci aux équipes du mag et
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission retrouver à free connecte sur
nos réseaux sociaux et notre site
internet rt france pointe et merci à
vous de votre attention et à très
bientôt dans les frais connecte sur rt
france